if I just go with scripture and I see
what scripture teaches then according to
scripture
children are under God's mercy and
Grace and
compassion up until the moment they are
aware that they exist and God exists and
they're responsible to keep God's law
now the Bible doesn't give you an age so
it doesn't generalize because each
child's development will vary from child
to child but I'm not going to give you
scripture going to give you scripture
Bible to show you that the Bible shows
that God is full of compassion and mercy
and pity for children who are not mature
enough to understand they exist God
exists and they're responsible to obey
God's law now I'm going to prove it from
scripture which means if you have a baby
in the
womb that baby is under the mercy and
compassion of God Deuteronomy 139 if you
don't mind the context is
that first generation of Israelites that
came out of Egypt they all died with the
exception of Joshua and Caleb because
God was disgusted with them and part of
their punishment was this all of you
will die in the wilderness even Moses
died and Aaron and Miriam the only two
from that first generation that entered
was Joshua and Caleb you're gonna die
but your children will enter so 40 years
later their children are now adults they
enter but their parents and grandparents
all died and here's why God allowed
their children to enter 40 years later
but the parents because of their
grumbling and complaining died in the
wilderness and Moses died in the
wilderness Aaron died in the wilderness
Miriam died in the wilderness only
Joshua Caleb from that first generation
entered here here's why moreover your
little ones and your children who you
say will be victims that I brought them
out to die as victims who today have no
knowledge of Good and Evil they shall go
in there to them I will give it and they
shall possess it so you see what he said
your children who do not know between
good and evil I'll have mercy and
compassion on them but I will punish you
and they will enter and you
won't so you see God why did God allowed
them to enter and not punish them
because they were so young they were
premature didn't know good and evil so
they're under the grace compassion and
mercy of God so God pied them right
Isaiah 75- 16 Isaiah 7:1 15-
16 Isaiah 7:15 talking about the
Messianic Child Jesus is a true human
being who is sinless and impeccable as a
human being still being a true human
being he had to learn and grow the
difference is because he's one Divine
person his learning process was governed
by him by his deity so that whatever
information he took in he took it in
flawlessly without error and that's the
miracle of the Incarnation but anyway
notice what it says about him Isaiah
7:15 to 16 Kurds and honey he shall eat
that he may know to refuse the evil and
choose the good so as a developing human
he will come to a point and be mature
enough to know this is evil and I'll
reject it and I'll only accept the good
because he's sinless and impeccable for
before the child shall know
to refuse the evil and choose the good
did you catch
it yeah the land that you dread will be
forsaken by both her Kings so there is a
time in which a child doesn't know
enough to distinguish good and evil
right so this means that child is
innocent is Guiltless so he'll be under
the grace and mercy and compassion of
Our Lord now Jonah 411 why did God
why did God spare my ancestors the
Assyrians their Capital being the great
City Nineveh why did he spare them from
destruction Jonah 4:11 here's what he
says to Jonah and should I not pity
Nineveh which was the capital of the
Assyrian Empire that's my ancestors in
which are more than 120,000 persons who
cannot are unable to discern between
their right and their left hand and much
livestock so wait Jonah there's more
than 100,00 who are too
young not mature enough to know the
difference between their right and left
you didn't want me to have compassion on
them and the
livestock you caught it yeah that's the
third text
right now let's go to Matthew
18 Matthew
18 let's read verses 1 to
7 okay Matthew 18 verses 1-
7 okay now watch read with me at that
time the disciples came to Jesus saying
who then
is greatest in the kingdom of heaven
then Jesus called a little child to him
so who's the greatest
children why if children can be punished
and go to hell why would they be the
greatest then Jesus called little child
to him set him in the midst of them
assuredly I say to you unless you are
converted and become as little children
so I as an adult need to be a child
again see you will by no means enter the
king of Heaven that makes no sense if
children are not
viewed under the compassionate loving
merciful Eyes Of God see you'll by no
means enter the Kingdom of Heaven
therefore whoever humbles himself as
this little child so you got to become a
child be like this
child innocent holding no grudges and
that's true with children you get a
child angry five minutes later the child
forgets and you put BL black children
white children Hispanic children
Assyrian children they don't see race or
color you take a young child male and
female put them naked no lust the child
doesn't the boy doesn't start lusting
for the girl the girl doesn't start
lusting for the boy and though the child
can sometimes be unruly the child
immediately runs to the parent clings to
the parent has absolute trust in the
parent and doesn't doubt that the
parents love and compassion that's how
God wants you to
be
assuredly I say to you unless you are
converted and become as Little Children
You Will by no means enter the Kingdom
of Heaven therefore whoever humbles
himself as the little child is the
greatest in the Kingdom of Heaven
whoever receives one little child like
this in my name receives me whoever
causes one of these little ones who
believe in me to sin it would be better
for him Muhammad Muslims if Millstone
were hung around his neck and he were
drowned in the depth of the
sea take heed that you do not despise
one of these little ones for I say to
you that in heaven their Angels always
see the face of my father who is in
heaven for the son of man has come to
save that which was
lost so there you go do you see what 8
to 10 says now I want to see
if you guys are paying attention to this
I hope it's not boring you guys we have
to change the theme you see what our
lord said now here's what's beautiful
eight and nine I want you to catch it if
your hand or foot cause you to S cut it
off and cast it from you it is better
for you to enter into life lame or MIM
rather than having two hands or two feet
to be cast into the everlasting life I
don't know if you caught it guys now
Focus guys don't start a debate in the
comment section let's learn I don't know
if you caught it he's talking about the
afterlife he says if your hand will
cause you to stumble cut it off because
better to enture life M right than to go
to hell whole do you guys catch it do
you see what Jesus called life he didn't
call this life life this life you live
is not true life he called the
afterlife that life that we Believers
will enjoy by the grace of Christ he
called that life
you understand if you're a True Believer
who loves Jesus this is not the ideal
life this life is not ideal true life
that which is really life is the life to
come where we will dwell with Christ and
be perfected that's what he said enter
life that means when we enter this world
we enter death so there you go for Jesus
life is not this world when you enter
this world you're entering death
life is the life to come with Jesus
where you're perfected and
glorified isn't that true Ortho Christos
and yet how many of us read it and
Overlook its impact and implication he
said it better enter life M well hold on
I'm already in life no this is not life
this is
dying you make the most of this life do
all you can to glorify Christ in this
world make Christ rule a reality in this
world but realize true life real life as
that life that awaits you in Jesus
Christ either when he summons you or
when he returns and transforms you and
the world pay attention to his words but
then now notice the key Matthew 18:10
take heed that you do not despise one of
these little ones for I say to you that
in
heaven right their Angels always see the
face of my father who is in heaven so
there you go now let me finish this here
here you're told by Jesus Christ you're
told by Jesus
Christ that children have Angels
assigned to them now he's talking about
two kinds of children he's talking about
physical children and spiritual babes
because he's not just talking about
physical children he's using physical
children as an illustration of spiritual
babes those who are recent converts
those who are born of spirit and are
babies spiritually they have angels of
assigned to them who intercede for them
so don't mess with them now to wrap it
up go to Matthew 19 brother now Matthew
19 13- 15 what does the Lord say
about about children Matthew 19 13-
15 I don't know why it went back to 18
that's all right brother okay now go to
13 scroll down okay here you go let the
children come to me here you go then
little children were brought to him that
he might put his hands on them and pray
but the disciples rebuked them but Jesus
said let the little children come to me
and do not forbid them for such is the
Kingdom of Heaven you caught it and he
laid his hands on them departed from
there the kingdom belongs to these
children can the message be any clear
the children own the kingdom the kingdom
belong to such children may the Lord
save me from misspeaking and error for
the glory of Jesus Christ and be
passionate and uncompromising and not
sin in my righteous anger for the glory
of Jesus our lord the kingdom belong to
such
children the kingdom is theirs how can
can Jesus be any clearer now the final
line of evidence for all of you Romans
4:15 Romans 513 States something that is
clear as day Romans 4:15 look what Paul
says because the law brings about wrath
for where there is no law there is no
transgression I repeat pay
attention where there is no law there is
no sin I want you to remember this point
of Paul F guys Focus Paul says when you
don't have law you're not
accountable because you do not know and
what you don't know you won't be
accountable for now Romans 5:13 because
I'm tied in with us Romans 5:13
Romans
5:13 for until the law was in the world
but sin is not imputed when there is no
law guys are you paying attention sin is
not
imputed when there is no law did we
catch this because if I'm doing it for
you guys to answer the question because
the other guy bailed out do you see what
Paul
says sin is not counted against you if
there's no law if there's no law you're
not accountable for sin
now how does this apply to us now let's
read Romans 7: 7-2 this is one of the
passages that showed me Calvinism is a
Lie from the pit of Hell let's read what
shall we say then is the law sin because
I broke the law and I brought death upon
myself does that mean the law is evil
certainly not the law is not evil on the
contrary I would not have known here's
the key guys I would not have
known sin except through the law I
wouldn't even know what sin is if the
law didn't tell me without the law I
don't know what sin is for I would not
have known that
covetousness unless the law had said You
shall not covet it's because of the law
I now know what sin is if there's no law
what is sin well sin is breaking the law
well how do you break the law here you
go but sin now he talks about Sin
as an in inclination a
proclivity as some element that is part
of your flesh he's now going to describe
sin as a proc proclivity an element an
inclination that's there and has a mind
of its own notice how he's going to
describe sin guys you got to listen
because I'm doing it for you guys I'm
doing this so you can see but sin taking
Opportunity by the Commandment produced
in me all manner of evil desire for
apart from the law sin was dead this is
why Paul is a genius you see how much
wisdom the holy spirit filled him with
mind-blowing what he's saying now what
does he mean here Paul is saying because
of Adam and
Eve we now have physical bodies that
have this sinful
proclivity sinful inclination but the
sinful inclination is dormant it's
asleep when is it aroused when I reach
the age of being aware God's law once I
come to the realization God has a law I
have to obey that then awakens sin in me
and now
sin pushes me tempts me drives me to
break it but prior to that moment sin
was asleep in my body okay I was alive
once without the law this is where I
knew Calvinism was a lie from the pit of
Hell because Calvinism says you're born
dead in sin Paul says no I'm not I you I
was alive I wasn't born dead I was alive
and then I died destroying total
depravity this lie of Calvinism here it
is I was alive once without the law but
when the Commandment came when I as an
individual realized the Commandment when
I reached an age of accountability where
now I could discern
oh we Israelites have a god
and that God has given me a law and that
law I must keep once the Commandment
came to me and I became aware of it sin
awoken and I died and the Commandment
which was to bring life I found to bring
death for sin that sinful proclivity
taking occasion by the Commandment
deceived me and by it killed me
therefore the law is Holy and the
Commandment holy and just and good now
do you understand what the Bible
actually teaches it teaches that you're
born born
alive but you have a sinful proclivity
inclination but that
sin is
dormant because if you do not know to
distinguish between right and wrong
because you are premature and you don't
have awareness and you don't have
cognition aware that God exists and he
has a law that I have to submit to
You're Now under God's grace mercy love
and compassion
but once I become aware hey man the god
of Israel requires me to obey him I
better start obeying him that's When sin
awakens makes me break the command and
that's when I die that's Biblical
teaching not this perverted doctrine of
total depravity of
Calvinism everyone got
it this is teaching so if we go with
this that means the Bible clearly
teaches children who are not mature
enough to know the difference between
right and wrong between their right and
their left who are not aware there's a
law that I'm obligated to they're under
the mercy compassion love and pity of
our God but once they reach the age of
what we call accountability but it
varies that's why there is no set law
given in the Bible because individuals
develop differently one individual
develops either faster or slower than
another and God knows that better than
us and he takes that into accountability
and has Mercy but this is why Jewish
tradition came up with an age of
accountability Bar Mitzvah the age of 13
for a male and the age of 12 and a half
for the
female you with me
there you with me
there even the Jews recognize the age of
accountability but they set it at 13 for
males 12 and a half for a female a woman
who's B
Mitzvah is now held accountable because
she's mature enough she's mature enough
right to be held accountable to keep the
law or suffer the consequences for the
boy it's 13 he's Bar Mitzvah in fact you
know what bar mitzvah means bar means
son Mitzvah of the Commandment you are
now a son of the Commandment meaning now
you're accountable to obey the
Commandment or you will P be punished
for the woman it's called B because the
word bat means daughter B mitvah so
Jewish tradition assigned the age of
accountability at 13 and 12 and a half
the Bible doesn't give you an age
because God In His Infinite Wisdom knows
children vary in their development so
you can have a seven-year-old who's
already mature more so than a 12-y old
so what's my answer if I follow
scripture children before they reach an
age of discernment of cognition and
awareness they're under the mercy of God
the pity of God which would extend to
The Unborn Child in the mother's womb so
if they die they're under the blood of
Christ under the grace of Christ born of
the spirit that's my understanding from
scripture